the couple leaving right now is in the
bottom two though yeah
what's happening that was the scariest
thing ever we were on such a high from
tonight because we got the highest
scores of the night our highest scores
we've ever had and it just honestly
dancing tonight's dance felt like a
dream I remember being in there and just
feeling and then listening to the music
and just looking at Lexington I was like
this is awesome
so I was really excited that we got such
a good score and the judges really
praised Alexis and then it was really
scary
whoa no comment your smile the entire
time that he's talking and now there's
been a lot of chatter tonight about your
guys's chemistry what's going on here is
there anything going on I mean we're
just we're just so happy to be here and
like I love him so much and I love his
energy so much and just we've been so
focused on the competition I feel like
the experiences it's once-in-a-lifetime
and we're just we're making the most of
it and really just going out there and
having fun do you ever see a turning
romancer again we're taking one day at a
time
[Music]
Halloween night magic what do you guys
have up your sleeve a lot of tricks and
a lot of treats but there's only three
women left in the competition the girls
going home in a row I just I really hope
that at least all the women but at least
us I hope we can start connecting to the
audience man you know I feel like Alexis
is so empowering when she dances and so
beautiful to see
so hopefully double elimination next
week why would you even bring that up
you're trying to have a beautiful Disney
night and you bring that up I'm just
curious about your mind at all is there
double elimination no elimination
tonight so maybe don't know that's the
one thing we know is that we don't know
math wasn't my strong suit survivor I
didn't really know any extra pressure
you know what I'm feeling I'm feeling
really good about our scores from
tonight and hopefully that's the
audience really liked our dances and
hopefully that's going to give us a
little push
you